Good morning everyone.
Would you please open your Bibles to Ephesians chapter two,
Ephesians chapter two.
We'll be there in just a minute.
Uh, John and Emily are away
enjoying a much needed break,
and John will be back next week to continue our series.
But today you're stuck with me.
Uh, my name is Aaron Ferguson. I'm one of the elders here.
It's a pleasure to serve you as an elder
and, uh, if you are new with us today,
thank you for being here.
We have a place just in the lobby called New here
and we would love to meet you
and, uh, get to know that you are here today.
Uh, the rest of you, I do not get this chance very often,
and so let me just say on behalf of the Elder Council
that uh, we are grateful for you.
We are, uh, grateful for your faithful attendance
and grateful for your faithful service.
Many of you serve all across the campus
in various ministries.
Thank you. And thank you for your faithful giving
and um, your faithful study of God's word.
It's my pleasure to lead
that study this morning in Ephesians chapter two.
Now, John, the last two weeks, uh,
has preached in a very low chair
and, uh, I am so grateful I don't have to do
that today for a couple of reasons.
Number one, I'm not cool enough to do that,
but number two, I'm getting to the age where if I set
that long, that low of the floor,
I probably wouldn't be able to get up
and, uh, they'd have to carry me off the stage.
And so that would be very embarrassing.
So I'm glad I don't have to do that.
And I'm getting to the age now where I, I used to be able
to preach with a small piece of paper
and I could read the fine print
and uh, now I have this massive notebook
with massive print in it and uh, I have to wear these.
Anybody have to wear these.
Uh, I know a lot of you have been wearing these your whole
life and I'm very sorry for that
'cause these are no fun at all.
Uh, Genesis chapter three, uh,
Eve ate that fruit because it was good for the eyes.
I think that was a lie. It was not good for the eyes at all.
Uh, poor eyesight is part of the curse, I'm convinced.
And uh, that's probably why I don't eat fruit either
'cause it's part of the curse.
But, uh, anyway, the good news about losing your eyesight is
that I'm starting to, I think,
get better looking in my old age as far
as I can tell in the mirror.
Uh, so there are some benefits.
We are in a series called First Things First,
looking at essential doctrines of the Christian life, sort
of those first tier, first level beliefs, the big rocks
that we should all agree on.
And uh, as I watched John last week,
put these rocks in here, I leaned over to my wife
and said, I hope there's room for my rock.
Uh, and so I asked this morning to, for the rocks
to be put in here before I preached,
because I was afraid that I wouldn't stack them properly
and my rock wouldn't fit in the jar like it's supposed to.
So you could say that John's a little bolder than I am,
but uh, I am not going to put these rocks in here,
but I am gonna review.
Uh, so far we've looked at five big rocks,
big tear issues, uh,
and we started with God's revelation,
how he has revealed himself to us through Christ,
through creation, through his word.
We believe the Bible is God's word.
And then we looked at week two, God's attributes.
Who is God? What is he like?
And then we looked at the person of the Trinity, the person
of Christ, and then last week, humanity.
Uh, who are we and why are we here? What are we like?
And uh, I guess you could say we're off to a rocky start,
but it's gonna get better today
because we're doing the doctrine of salvation.
So, uh, why is the doctrine of salvation a big rock
that we need to spend a whole sermon on it?
Well, it's really the heart of the gospel.
It's the heart of the entire Bible.
The message of the entire Bible from beginning to end is
God redeeming, fallen people.
And so when we talk salvation, we're really getting right
to the heart of what God wants to say to us.
And besides that, we answer some of life's big questions
with the doctrine of salvation.
Like, why am I here and, and what's wrong with me?
And what can I do about it?
Uh, how can I be made right with God again and,
and what happens to me when I die?
Now those are some big questions that the doctrine
of salvation is going to answer.
So this is a foundation stone, a big rock for sure,
and it's so big
and intimidating that uh, we could spend a year
of sermons on this doctrine.
You understand? On Wednesday night, I'm going to try
to go in a lot more deeply than I am this morning.
This morning I'm gonna try to keep this very simple
and I'm gonna do that by asking and answering six questions.
So you'll see, uh, there on your notes the six questions,
and I'm just gonna dive right in
and begin to answer these questions.
So what is salvation? What is salvation?
The Greek word for salvation literally means to save
or to rescue, to save or to rescue.
Uh, Noah Webster's definition of salvation is the act
of saving or preserving someone from danger or destruction.
The act of saving or preserving someone
from danger or destruction.
Okay, well that caused me to ask five more questions.
Uh, who is it that needs to be saved? Who needs to be saved?
Why do we need to be saved?
Who is it that does the saving?
How are we saved and what are the benefits of being saved?
All five questions can be answered in our key passage today.
Ephesians chapter two verses one through 10.
So would you join me there? Ephesians chapter two,
verses one through 10.
This is an incredible passage
and the gospel is just richly described
and I'm gonna try to make it as simple as I can.
Ephesians chapter two, verse one,
and you Christians, Paul's talking to Christians,
you were dead in the trespasses
and sins in which you once walked following the course
of this world, following the prince of the power of the air,
the spirit that is now at work in the sons of disobedience,
among whom we all once lived in the passions of our flesh,
carrying out the desires of the body and the mind
and were by nature, children
of wrath like the rest of mankind.
But God being rich in mercy and
because of the great love with which he loved us
even when we were dead in our trespasses,
made us alive together with Christ by grace,
have you been saved and raised us up with him
and seeded us with him in the heavenly places
in Christ Jesus.
So that in the coming ages
he might show the immeasurable riches of his grace
and kindness toward us in Christ Jesus.
For by grace have you been saved through faith.
And this is not your own doing, it's the gift of God,
not a result of work so that no one may boast
for we are his workmanship, created in Christ Jesus
for good works, which God prepared beforehand
that we should walk in them.
Well, let's pray together. God, thank you
so much for your word.
Thank you for this passage on salvation.
I pray now that you would help me to make it
as clearly clear as I can pray
that you would open our hearts
and our minds to understand what it is you have done
for us in this wonderful gift of salvation.
It's in Christ name we pray. Amen.
Well, let's answer that second question.
Who is it that needs to be saved?
Well find the answer in verse three.
If you'll go back to verse three.
Paul is speaking to Christians
and he's describing our lives
before salvation, that we all lived
in a way that displeased God, read this verse with me again.
Among whom we Christians all
once lived in the passions of our flesh,
carrying out the desires of the body and the mind
and were by nature children
of wrath like the rest of mankind.
If you like to underline, circle, highlight words,
encourage you to to underline, highlight,
circle in verse three.
We all, we all, Paul says, we all Christians
included, used to live in a way that displeased God
and then underline, highlight circle
like the rest of mankind.
All of us live in a way
that displeases God.
In other words, everyone needs to be saved.
Salvation is for everyone.
Everyone needs salvation. Without salvation, we are doomed.
Which Paul is gonna go on
to explain more here in just a minute.
Why? Why do we need to be saved?
Let's answer question number three.
Why do we need to be saved?
Paul describes what we are like before salvation.
In verses one through three,
lemme just read some of these statements.
Verse one, he says, we are dead in our trespasses and sins.
Verse two, we follow the prince of the power of the air.
Also in verse two, we follow the course of this world.
And then also in verse two, we are sons of disobedience.
And then in verse three, we are children of wrath.
Without salvation, our condition is hopeless.
And what he's trying to show us is we are
hopeless without salvation.
So let me just for a a minute here,
explain those five statements as best I can.
Number one, we are dead in our trespasses and sins.
Genesis chapter two, God tells Adam
and Eve not to eat from a certain tree.
But look, listen to verse 17.
In the day that you eat of it, you will surely die.
In the day that you disobey me, you will surely die.
What God is doing there right at the beginning of our Bibles
is establishing a principle.
Death is a penalty for disobedience.
Death is a penalty for sin.
If you obey me, you live. If you disobey me, you die.
And of course we know what happens.
Adam and Eve disobey God, they rebel against him
and sin enters to the world and they die.
Not immediately physically, but they died spiritually.
They will die later physically. Death is a penalty for sin.
It's part of the curse of the fall.
You're familiar with Romans 6 23, the wages of sin is death.
You know that Romans five in verse 12, just
as sin entered the world through one man, that's Adam death
through sin.
Paul says, remember that death is the penalty for sin.
And so death spread to all men
because all sinned,
we are born spiritually dead.
The Bible says we're conceived in sin.
We are spiritually dead.
I know you're alive physically someday you're going
to die physically.
But right now we are born spiritually
dead before salvation.
So why do we need to be saved?
We are dead in our trespasses and sins.
And then Paul says, we follow the prince
of the power of the heir.
What in the world does that mean?
That's just a description of Satan whom
Jesus called the prince of demons, the ruler of this world.
And you and I know we live in a physical world,
tangible world that we can see and touch,
but there's another world,
a spiritual world we can't see and we can't touch.
And Satan is a very much a real part of that world
and he's the ruler of that spiritual darkness.
That's why Paul says Ephesians chapter six,
we do not wrestle against flesh and blood, what we can see
and touch, but against the rulers,
against the cosmic powers over this present darkness,
the other world against the spiritual forces
of evil in heavenly places.
Satan is the prince of that darkness,
that spiritual darkness Paul is talking about.
You and I are born dead in our trespasses and sins
and we're also born into spiritual darkness.
And that means Satan has a great deal of influence
and control in our lives.
Before salvation, we are dead
and we are in darkness is the way Paul is describing this.
Listen to Colossians chapter one, verse 13.
When we are saved, when we give our lives to Christ,
he has delivered us from the domain of darkness
and transferred us to the kingdom
of his beloved son into light
before salvation, we are dead
and we are in darkness, trapped in
Satan's control, the prince of the power of the air.
That's how we are. That's how we come into this world.
And then Paul says, we follow the course of this world.
What does that mean? Because we are born dead
and we are born in that spiritual darkness
and Satan has a lot of control and influence in our lives.
Uh, he's working to conform us into his image.
He's working to mold us into his image, the views
and values of this fallen world.
That's why Paul says in Romans 12,
do not be conformed to this world.
Satan is trying to mold you, shape you into his image.
This world is fallen, broken, sinful.
But that's what Satan is trying to mold you into.
Listen to one John two 15 and 16. Do not love the world.
Do not love the things in the world. Why not?
Because they are not of God. They are of the world.
Satan is influencing you, controlling you
to mold you into his image,
and he wants you to follow the course of this world.
Our condition before salvation is hopeless, spiritually,
dead, dark, under the control, the influence of Satan,
and he's molding us the way he wants us before salvation.
We are hopeless.
And then Paul calls us in verse two, sons of disobedience.
Why does he call us sons of disobedience in our sin?
We don't love God. We love ourselves in our sin.
We don't obey God. We do what we want to do.
We disobey God.
Remember, we're under Satan's control
and he wants us to rebel against God just like he did
and disobey his commands.
That's why Paul says in Romans three, none is righteous.
No not one. No one understands.
No one seeks for God
because we are rotten, fallen, just like our first parents.
We've inherited that sinful nature.
Later Paul says in Romans 3 23, all have sinned
and fall short of the glory of God.
Just like Adam and Eve, they disobeyed God.
They handed down that sinful nature to their descendants.
That's us. We are disobedient to God at first.
We don't have a choice. That's our nature.
We are sons of disobedience.
And then verse three, Paul says, we are children of wrath
because we are born dead.
We're born into that darkness. We're under Satan's control.
We rebel against God just like he did.
We disobey his commands.
We deserve God's wrath,
his judgment, his punishment.
Why do we need to be saved?
Because our condition before salvation is hopeless.
Now there's more to the story.
Aren't you glad there's good news this morning?
Let's answer question number four. Who does the saving?
Who does the saving? If we are dead in our trespasses
and sins, dead men can't resuscitate themselves.
Who does the saving?
Well, perhaps the sweetest words in this passage, you need
to underline, highlight, circle, star,
beginning of verse four.
But God, but God,
you were born dead in your trespasses and sin,
but God made you alive.
You were born into spiritual darkness,
but God transferred you into the kingdom
of His Son into light.
You were, you were, you were,
but God, but God.
So then who does the saving? It's God alone.
Who does the saving? Salvation is entirely
a work of God.
We cannot save ourselves.
God has to do the saving.
Salvation is entirely a work of God.
But why would he do that? Why would he do that?
Paul goes on verses four and five,
but God listen to some key words, being rich in mercy.
God is merciful because of his great love.
God is loving with which he loved us
even when we were dead in our trespasses.
He made us alive together with Christ by grace.
Something we do not deserve.
By grace, have you been saved? He is merciful.
He is loving. He is gracious.
That's why he decided to save us.
Listen to Titus three.
He saved us not
because of works done by us in righteousness,
but according to His mer mercy.
God is merciful.
Romans chapter five, God shows his love for us
and that while we were still sinners, Christ died for us.
God is loving.
Second to Timothy one, nine, God who saved us
and called us to a holy calling.
Not because of our works, but
because of his own purpose and grace.
God is gracious mercy, love and grace.
We didn't deserve it. We couldn't earn it.
He had to do it for us.
Salvation is entirely a work of God,
not of our own doing.
Skip on down there in Ephesians two to verse 10.
I love this. Paul says, we are his workmanship.
Shorten that to we are his work. It's his work.
He's the one that saves us, not ourselves.
We were dead once, but God gave us life.
We were rotten, but God made us right.
We were slaves once, but God set us free.
If no, but God, where would we be?
Only by the grace of God are we saved.
Who does the saving? Salvation
is entirely a work of God.
How does he do it? How are we saved?
Let's answer that question. How are we saved?
You know, the world would say we're saved by our works.
Things that we can do. We can earn the righteousness of God.
You know, before sin entered into the world,
that might have been true.
Adam and Eve were told, if you obey me, you live.
If you disobey, you die.
Their lives were dependent on their obedience, their works.
But you and I know what happened. They disobeyed.
They rebelled against God and sin entered into the world.
And you and I inherited that sinful nature.
So now after sin works don't work,
we fall short of God's standard of righteousness.
We are incapable of earning salvation.
So God had to make a way for us to be saved.
How did he do it? He sent his only son,
Jesus Christ, who came
conceived by the spirit born of a virgin
and who lived a sinless life, meaning
that he obeyed God perfectly, which Adam did not do.
Christ obeyed.
God perfectly, lived a sinless life.
And that penalty for sin is still there.
Death is still the penalty for sin.
But God said this because my son has lived a sinless life.
I will accept his death on your behalf.
I will accept his sacrifice
and spare you the penalty for your sin.
So he died on a cross
for you and for me.
That sinless life.
God took and he gave it to you
and he took your sin and he put it on Christ.
And Christ sacrificed himself on that cross for you
to have salvation,
you and I cannot save ourselves.
Only God can do the work.
And he did the work through his son, Jesus Christ. But how?
How are we saved?
Paul answers this question in verses eight and nine.
We're saved by grace. We don't deserve it.
Through faith. Through faith. What is faith?
Faith is a trust in
what Christ has done on our behalf.
We believe that his work on the cross
will save us from the penalty of sin.
If we put our faith in Jesus, God will accept his death
on our behalf and he will give us eternal life
and righteousness right standing with him.
Instead, he exchanges Christ's righteousness
for our sinfulness through faith.
We have to trust that, believing that that is true.
I've had a suitcase up here this whole time.
You've been wondering why it's here.
If you were planning on going on a trip for about a year
and you had a lot of things that you need to get in order
to do that, a lot of packing to do, and a friend came to you
and said, you don't have to do a thing,
I've packed your bag for you.
Really? Yes, I've packed your bag for you.
Everything you need for a year is in that suitcase.
Would you believe your friend
and would you trust your friend
that he's got everything in the bag that you need?
Yeah, I don't think so. No, no, no, no. It's in the bag.
Did you remember to get it's in the bag? Really?
Okay, I believe you. I trust you.
I'm gonna put my faith in you
and accept that the suitcase has everything I need.
God, the Father has made a way for you
and I to be right with him again.
To be saved from the penalty of sin, to escape
the curse of death
and have eternal life through Jesus Christ.
God has offered you a free gift.
You have done nothing to deserve it, nothing to earn it.
It's just His grace, his goodness,
everything you need to be right with God
to live eternally with him in heaven.
Everything you need to have new life, new hope,
a second chance, it's in the bag.
What do you do?
Put your hope and faith and trust in the God.
Do you trust God at His word?
Do you believe that the gift has everything you
need to be right with him?
Again,
what's in the bag?
What are the benefits of salvation?
Let's answer that last question.
To be honest with you, they are endless. They are endless.
The benefits of being saved are endless.
I could spend a year of sermons on this.
We're gonna try to dive a little more
deeply on Wednesday nights.
Uh, we, this coming Wednesday night at six
15, right in here.
I'll try to answer that question a little more fully.
But there are three benefits in this passage. Verse five.
Paul says, even when we were dead in our trespasses,
he made us alive together with Christ.
One of the benefits of salvation is you're not dead anymore.
You have new life in Christ.
You're not spiritually dead.
You're spiritually alive in him.
He has resurrected your dead spirit
and made it alive with Christ.
You're no longer part of Satan's dominion.
You're not in that darkness anymore.
You've been transferred to the kingdom of his beloved son.
You are now in the light with Christ.
New life right here on Earth.
A second chance, verse 10.
Paul says, we have a new mission and a new purpose in life.
We are his workmanship.
Paul says, created in Christ Jesus for good works.
We have a new mission and a new purpose in life.
God has things for us to do
after salvation,
like telling other people the good news of salvation.
We have a new mission, a new purpose to walk
and live for Christ.
And then verse six, Paul says, we have eternal life.
He raised us up with him
and seeded us with him in the heavenly
places in Christ Jesus.
We no longer have to fear the curse and the penalty of sin
because we have life eternal.
We don't have to fear death anymore.
Physical death, spiritual death. It's in the bag.
Eternal life.
The doctrine of salvation is amazing,
but it's more than just a doctrine.
We're talking the difference between life and death.
And you and I can only stand back
and say, we have an amazing God.
We don't understand it all.
I didn't deserve any of this, but thank you, God.
You are gracious and good and merciful.
Thank you God for the gift of salvation.
And that's why I love verse seven.
In the coming ages, he might show us
the immeasurable riches of his grace
in kindness toward us in Christ Jesus.
You know why we get to live eternally with Jesus Christ
and God because it's gonna take an eternity to praise him
for everything that he is done for us.
The benefits are endless,
and it's gonna take all of eternity to thank him
for everything he's done for us.
That's amazing. We were dead once,
but God gave us life.
We were rotten. But God made us right.
We were slaves once, but God set us free.
If no, but God, where would we be?
The doctrine of salvation, beautiful,
powerful, transformative.
Some of you I know in this room have
put your faith in Christ
and you've been walking
with him faithfully your whole life.
He is your life. You live for him. You share others.
Share with others what he's done for you.
Some of you, uh, a better description might be, you know
what God has done for you
and you are hanging on to Christ with everything you've got.
Not because you've earned your salvation
or you're gonna lose it, but
because you know what God has done for you in salvation.
Some of you are not so sure
you've heard me today,
but you're like, yeah, I don't know about that.
I'll save myself. I'll trust in myself.
Well, I've got bad news for you. That's a dead end.
You are spiritually dead. You're in the kingdom of darkness.
You're under the control, the influence of the enemy,
and you are rotten to the core.
In one of these days. You're gonna have to stand in front
of the Lord and be held accountable for
what you have done at that point.
It's too late. You'll be judged, you'll be sentenced.
You'll be condemned to an eternal punishment
in a place called hell.
Do not miss your opportunity today
to accept the free gift of God in salvation.